here he comes right now an icon hello of
cinema and culture
he's a taste maker he's John Waters
welcome thank you do you consider
yourself that yeah you can if you want
do I consider what
consider yourself that and I'm an iconic
well I transcend that I try to be
humbled for your filth
Eldar that kind of makes it sound a
little more home dick do you think
people's openness is kind of caught up
to the way you always saw things yeah I
didn't change so much I mean my last
movie was about sex addict saw this book
mr. know-it-all has chapters about sex
clubs in New York and how I'm gonna beat
death and crawl out from under the mud
and yeah so I I think I don't think I've
changed that much I think the humor that
I've always liked has become more just
American have you gone to sex clubs oh
yeah the old days everybody went you
went every night it was amazing give it
up what we tried to the vault we tried
to go one so by the time we went had
moved it was just some guys apartment
the Hellfire was the best one because it
was straight and gay was that in the
meat packing though they all were in the
meat bag now all these really fancy
restaurants are there and I thought
hahaha wouldn't be how I don't remember
the stuff that went on in here it was
Hellfire like how far you walk down on
the dungeon and there was like a 200
pound woman and a nurse in a form of an
anima kit and women got in free and men
were $10 and you would just walk around
and it was mix of a straight and game
people a lot of intellectuals famous
people went there was slum touring right
and then you'd be talking in a glory
hole and then a penis would come through
a wall and hey in the back oh and just
move away and start talking about a new
novel or the literary editor Wow
unless you were by yourself and you
maybe address the penis there were some
people that did you you could
participate or not write it was safe to
go you could bring friends you might be
sitting there and she looked at somebody
had crawled over and licked your feed
you just kick them away so it was like
the Soho House but with dicks an enema
now is that because do you feel like
we're living in a time now where
labels for things are going away
straight gay and bi no glad for that I
think you should be able to decide it
depends on the person right and I I know
gay people have been men that have got
girlfriends and they get so much grief
for it I think you're allowed to come in
too and I
they have enough gay people I think you
should audition I think we have too many
now right become very in style well it's
also a class issue why is it okay to be
gay in rich kid school
not in poor kids great right no that's a
hundred percent there's a little rougher
in the inner cities when you're when
you're a guy who is a dealt in filth and
counterculture for your entire life
and filth and counterculture starts to
become more and more accepted and
sexuality becomes more and more accepted
and all these things that you did you
know in the 70s and 80s and 90s that
were taboo at the time become less and
less taboo do you find yourself having
to figure out what the new taboos are or
do you just say alright if the world's
catching up to me the world's catching I
think it's great it's exciting when
everybody else is finally laughing at
the same stuff um I never just tried to
shock you because that's not that's easy
and not witty or funny I use humor to
get your attention so you might change
your mind about something or or consider
something in a different way I'm always
drawn to subject matter but kind of
appalls me that I don't know the answer
to I didn't you know there's I'm not
that little I don't want to be an adult
baby I'm not marching for them the guys
who want to be put in diapers and taught
a lesson
talk about faulty toilet training yeah
yeah it's know I've seen pictures of
them in bouncy chairs sucking their
thumb and a diaper I thought I'm sorry
I'm not marching for you yes yeah I
don't understand the turn-on of it
does it bother you though that a lot of
it has been sanitized as well look at
42nd Street it's not what it used to be
again me pal no kidding now a pretty
sucker Street is like suburbia that I
came to New York to escape half of New
York is what I came to escape the new
malls and you know so the New York that
I ran away when I was a teenager but I
think kids are having just as much fun
as we did as soon as you start to think
roll we had more fun in our generation
then you're an old fart and you lose
touch and you're not relevant anymore
well Baltimore was a pretty busy place I
mean it's not like in New York but it
was it was it rough when you were there
like it is now oh we got edge come on
down but it's also cheap enough to have
a Bohemia there so am I like Baltimore
even best even more than I ever did
actually and that is where my main place
where I live definitely what was it like
in in in the early 90s when suddenly the
work that you're doing becomes
mainstream you know you went through
Iran it was like hairspray and crybaby
and cereal mom and you went on this run
in the 90s where all of a sudden your
eye clawed my way to the top and then
fell right back I like both well I had
fun doing that you kidding about a house
I you know I yes it was fine
they paid that's what I say all the
movies that I first got famous for I
made almost no money on and all the big
movies later but lost money I made a lot
of money on because I got a paid a
salary that was the big difference and
how was it falling the falling was great
because because they paid me more each
time so in Hollywood it's an illusion of
success basically and Hollywood was fair
to me
the more money to give you the more
they're gonna have to say that's just
the way it works I don't have any
problem with everybody paid me and
everybody was fine in Hollywood when the
early 2000 start to pop up and they
stopped paying you to make movies
because they loved you when your movies
were making money and then they stopped
loving you when your movie stopped
making money you don't go through
depression or or a low or anything like
that when you realize oh that's all it
was because they gave me money to makes
us will be demented on a dirty shame and
then they played all over Europe and my
films still come out on criterion is
releasing again they did multiple
maniacs you know what we're doing
polyester now so they're still out there
they play on television they come out at
all different from food get turned into
musicals and so they're still out there
so I never felt that I got abandoned by
show business and spraying the last
books I wrote did better than the movies
so so I I just like to tell stories and
you did but you didn't feel like I'm
counterculture and now that culture kind
of likes me maybe I maybe I have to
reinvent things or do something
different or you do love the fact that
more people are enjoying it I like it
that more people do I always wanted to
be commercial I always wanted them to be
hits they just weren't although they
were weird hits for the for the audience
that they were you know designed for I
mean pink flamingos is still playing
yeah you know it only costs $12,000 for
almost 50 years ago and it's still
playing so I think that is a commercial
hip
the only difference is that like crybaby
and and serial mom and movies like that
still completely fit in your wheelhouse
it's just that now Kathleen Turner and
Johnny Depp are popping up in them right
yeah they were the same kind of movies
and Johnny Depp took a big chance to
work with me and Kathleen Turner I'm
still friends with him she's great I
think serial my was my best movie yeah
so um yeah all the stars I've worked
with they came along for the ride they
had a great time I didn't have problems
with any of them did you really talk him
out of marrying Winona Ryder
well that is got pulled off yes I did at
the time Johnny and Winona were together
and they were gonna get married and and
he got me ordained in the Universal Life
Church which I had done 17 marriages
since but I stopped doing it because
people wanted me as a photo-op basically
at their wedding so uh and I did kind of
talk him out of it because we're Nonna
was really young and they hadn't been
known each other that long
I liked him both and I was further a
love affair certainly but I was against
marriage period so I kind of talked him
out of it and I think her parents were
thankful not they like Johnny it was
just like she was really young how do
you think in Hollywood now compared to
when you were coming up and what you've
seen in the way Hollywood they're
different me too and all these things
that were going on and how is it like
how has it changed and what do you think
it was happening well now you need a
lawyer they have somebody for a date
yeah it's it's it's the opposite of
hellfire you want it so I've seen both
extremes you have to live and what's
happening I basically think most of it
is correct I think and what I read the
other day well I always said well do you
think it was bad in the movie business
think what it was like in McDonald's
where nobody had a mantel to complain
about it yeah and then yesterday I just
rather see a huge suit against
McDonald's about exact reason for sexual
harassment yeah so I think it's been
going on for a long time and and I
didn't ever get it because you know
Harvey didn't try to [ __ ] me do a lot of
things get a movie made do you feel like
writing books and and and doing your
spoken word tours and the stuff that
you're doing now is more in line with
who you were when you started making
films in the sense that you're such an
independent creator of stuff and when
you're making big movies it's difficult
to remain independent because there's
just so many
parts when you're writing a book it can
be you that's a shoe you'll have a lot
of researchers in my office but yes and
when I tour I tour it always with the
movies to to promote them you never can
stop touring you because that's
especially today that you have to be in
touch with your audience and what's kind
of great about today is everybody's cool
everywhere it's not like you'd go to Des
Moines and there's like people that have
never heard of anything they've heard of
everything as just as much as the people
who live in Manhattan is that the weird
arrogance of cities where they think
that like everybody in the Midwest is a
dope in New York that was yet they know
everything because of the internet and
everything so that it's completely
different you don't have to move to New
York anymore you have to get noticed in
New York but you don't have to live here
anymore it's so expensive that I don't
know is there a youthful idea could it
breathe in Manhattan today could it's so
expensive could it ignite with some
radical kids starting something I don't
know you said you always want to be
mainstream - do you think the most like
you know kind of on the fringe artists
or alternative artists all deep down
want to be mainstream but after a while
if it doesn't look like it's happened
they just embrace where they are well I
think everybody wants to have some sort
of success I always say in the beginning
somebody beside you and your mother has
to think you're good but at the same
time there's some people Mike Kelly was
a great artist that I really liked and
he became so so accepted and famous I
think he committed suicide I think that
sometimes if you get too much success or
are you completely accepted and you were
always the bad boy you maybe don't know
how to handle that um I did because I
was always thrilled and excited and
amazed that this stuff could happen do
you think the people who have nothing to
push against anymore like they feel like
okay this is my whole thing is kind of
fighting my way to the top and then once
there's nothing to push but like pushing
back against them they just don't know
what to do well there's a lot to push
against these days no matter what you
believe in politically there's the
country's implicit split right down the
middle 50/50 so there's everybody's
pushing about everything it's it's how
to negotiate and that's the main thing
what you learn how to get through life
and to get through Hollywood to get
through and I have achieved the greatest
success and after 50 years I'm never
around [ __ ] and that has taken 50
years to figure out how to do that in
every part of my career how did you do
you know life you navigate an annual
Emma
eight the [ __ ] and you claw your way
over Ansel's to the good people and you
keep getting networking a terrible
yuppie word from people that aren't
[ __ ] and eventually you never have
to be around one anymore it's amazing
it's the American Dream is yeah do you
want to do to say what you want to say
and not be around [ __ ] but you're
not successful yeah I think that's a
hundred percent success you've had
moments since the 70s where you've been
under fire from critics and and you know
the before we had canceled culture you
were a part of it right have you had any
moments where you felt like oh no maybe
I pushed the envelope too far like
people are really mad this time I may
not be no buddy I got mad no never they
still don't cuz I make fun of things I
love I don't make things of fun of
things I hate I so people were able to
pick up on in the early movies they I
got terrible reviews but we put them in
the ads because it was a different time
the critics then were on the other side
there were straight what didn't mean gay
or it meant like they didn't smoke pop
or squares yeah yeah exactly right so I
remember when people used to says he's
ahead I forgot but but they were a
straight or a head and neither of the
things that sounds like today right it
just meant you smoke pot or didn't so so
it was a different time then today bad
reviews would hurt me yeah I can't use
them today really well today it's
different to be killing rotten tomatoes
and stuff that there's a bunch of people
saying it you could see what a bunch of
people are said as opposed to just one
guy who's gonna try to manipulate it too
that's that's the whole thing you know
and no Hollywood Studios they used to
always if they thought you were gonna
get a bad review this never happened
with me because they needed reviews from
art house theaters that I played him but
that they would not review it for
reviewers so they had from run it open
Friday to Sunday before the word mouth
got out but it was terrible today of
course in one second right after the
movie's over everybody's tweeting so
that's why you always hear upbeat music
and the tail credits when people are
walking out they want you to think oh I
liked it yeah yeah that's amazing yeah
because realistically the Internet has
made it so that it they're one second
everybody critics yeah you know it's not
like there's just more people in
newspapers every
single person that goes to the movie can
publish their review and not have to
sign their name ever yeah and this is a
no previews they would do like they'd
have no previous for the crazy is now
when you see the previews of coming
attractions to me I hate them because
they're 20 hours long and they to show
you the entire movie is basically the
pitch now I got the deal they want a big
Zack plot in order you don't have to see
the movie right you're pitching to the
audience now yeah I'm just saying hey
this cool things coming yeah well
there's too many of them and they're so
long I think what time why'd you say it
start at 8 o'clock
it's quarter of 9:00 with those horrible
things that say pre screen test like
when a director says ah does he mean
supposed to participate on your
smartphone yeah yeah it's like being at
Yankee Stadium and figuring I think the
blue trains gonna win okay it's a
constant noise constant they don't think
like you can't just sit there for a
moment and breathe and think about
something yeah but do you on your phone
a lot like if I'm in the dentist office
I'm like what the [ __ ] did I do before
my phone I forget what life is like
without afar what I did before my father
dentist's office was laughing gasps it's
hard to be on the dennis and we're
getting laughing this and doing your
phone getting your teeth filled at the
same time that's tough yeah you know a
lot of your stuff gets talked about
being ahead of its time but I think
thing that you did that was way far
ahead of its time it doesn't get enough
credit for being ahead of its time was
your episode of The Simpsons oh thank
you that kind of was ahead as far as a
big Network show to have the gay thing
on it was with Homer and I loved my
character said that Homer all steel
workers are gay I think it was I didn't
write that at all I had nothing to do it
and I think was a very well-written and
and children still would come over to me
in airports and because of it and
especially more so since I did the Alvin
the chipmunk movie now children asked me
to pick them up an AirPrint I see are
you you look like Chester the my can't
pick you up yeah a so you didn't write
it or anything but clearly the character
was designed for you because they you're
character was named John named John and
he was just a yellow version of you well
also buddy he owned an antique shop
words I never have done in my life or
anything but it was great and because of
that show I almost had a show on MTV
later called about me a fictitious
character that I developed with the
director Mike Anderson who did my
episode of the symptoms so it didn't
happen but it got close to in the crazy
they would what was the cartoon that
just wouldn't air in Alabama because
there was a gay character a gay wedding
they wouldn't air it I mean they've been
on a real kick lately haven't been a
Latina
yeah doctor coathangers gonna get back
yeah Alabama is doing everything they
can to prove your theory wrong there all
everybody in all states are cool now and
I'll BAM is like we won't accept you or
move here if you are an [ __ ] we want
to be around you yeah exactly exactly
all the [ __ ] that are bad either
I've been there there are plenty of cool
people I'm sure it's the politicians in
Alabama yeah yeah what do you think it
is as causing it to kind of swing back
that way because all this political
correct stuff makes them feel stupid and
they get angry and I understand that
it's like it's like a reaction to
feeling like this being whether it's
being made to feel stupid when they say
well is your childhood baby what the
hell is a baby that's when you have a
child and you don't tell them what suck
fire and they have to decide for
themselves baby I heard that a third a
new one you open your book talking a
little bit about like transit and stuff
like that which is great because people
get so upset if you reference it in
humor and you don't seem to be afraid of
catching I don't think it's funny I'm
amazed at how many people really are now
coming out of that closet and how many
people in the world are into that and I
think it's great I think you should be
allowed to go back and forth if you want
to so um I don't know that I have so
much humor about it except with parents
come to me and they don't know what to
do when their daughter comes home from
college and has a beard and has had a
breast removed and they don't really
know how to handle it which I get to you
know you got to ease your parents into
some of these things yeah babies I've
never heard before the babies are bottom
surgery is a hard concept for parents to
immediately accept so you have to give
them a little warning and a little a
little schooling about it too because
you can't say to a parent anymore did
you have a boy or a girl well it all
depends
ever shifting there's just boys or girls
anymore right and there they're kind of
isn't but at the same time you know I do
think that the parents that go the extra
mile and try to push that sort of non
identity onto kids or the parents that
have you know their six-year-old on
hormones already it's like let's all
relax for a second you know I mean the
thing is you're supposed to tell your
kid what to do in the beginning and it's
wrong they get to reject you yeah
exactly that's called created of being a
juvenile delinquent right yeah right you
can be too liberal it's it's tough you
know it to be a parent's heart my
parents didn't know what to do when they
had me I was born two months early I was
like a teacup baby and there I was
overly baptized and damaged and right
from the beginning
they knew that I weren't gonna be like
anybody else but they did their best you
know all you can do and you have a child
no matter what their look is to try to
make them feel safe and that's the
hardest thing you can do so for you it
wasn't one of those things where you got
out of Baltimore you moved to New York
and then you started to kind of let all
your quirkiness fly I never moved to New
York I mean I have an apartment here but
I stayed in Baltimore I still live there
but even as a little kid you were quirky
yeah but I ran away to New York I took
the Greyhound bus and came up here and
saw underground movies every midnight
count and everything even before you
know you know I wasn't much of a hustler
jacket the whole thing with the parents
to like like John Walker Lindh I think
with the the American talent I think he
had parents like that that were like
well he has great parents but it wasn't
a really open like in very hailer and
they've been supportive the whole time
and I believe that was a lot really over
exaggerated panic about him when that
whole thing happened to be honest right
I think it was hosteria about him but I
would say even when your parents are
that open and and good you still try to
find somebody to rebellion so it doesn't
matter their parents like they let him
do whatever he wants and they would
really like open people and is like
alright [ __ ] I'll join the Taliban
like whatever it is that just gets your
parents something something so what are
the odds that we get to a place in
society where you know what I'm really
gonna stick it to my parents I'm gonna
be a hetero cisgender white male well
gosh yeah it can happen but the thing is
if you're still trying to get back to
your parents over 30 something's a
matter with you I think you can blame
your parents till you're about 30 but
then get over it we all guilt Delta Han
it isn't fair yeah big boos so figure it
out you know if you're still complaining
about your parents just get away from
them or embrace them and make peace
because you turn into a weird version of
them anyway much later in life whether
you like it or not have you seen your
traits of your parents in you as you
begin oh yeah exactly and and and I
think I tried to the good ones I don't
think any of the bad ones I think I
tried to reject and I think they got
more liberal because of me and also I
always knew they were there for me so I
never really went off the deep end even
in the most extreme moments of my life
so I think that's incredibly important I
was very very lucky I had functional
parents I don't know why I'm so nuts now
really so when you have divine eating
feces dog feces on camera as everybody
knows about in the pink flamingo film
your parents are going are supporting
your art well my father paid for that
movie and he never saw it and I paid him
back which I think he was mad I paid him
back because he was not me to pay him
back so I'd never ask him again and uh
and he was amazed that I got these films
made that they were shown everywhere but
I'd get arrested you know there was
nobody saying they were good then right
but they were supportive yes they were
at what point did you dad and mom
realized what it was you're doing if he
wasn't seeing the films at what point
did he realize new because they were in
the paper and I was getting arrested
shading well he knew about that but
before that multiple maniacs Armando
treasurer I got arrested for conspiracy
to commit indecent exposure
shooting a scene on the college campus
of Johns Hopkins where he went and I was
a junior so we have the same name so my
dad my wife got my obscene phone calls
crime unlisted he wasn't we all seen
that your shoes but it was divine in a
1959 red Cadillac convertible in a gold
LeMay toreador a suit imagining a
hitchhiker is nude and picking him up
and we didn't ask I didn't know you're
supposed to ask permission we just went
Sunday morning and filmed it and they
called the police and we all ran and of
course Devine escaped with a nude man in
the car and dragged driving a Cadillac
convertible and
remember which does not say a lot for
the Baltimore police and there was no I
never got busted we are about and then
the Civil Liberties Union handled the
case oh they did this is in the paper a
lot my father was mortified they were
mortified by plenty you know and even at
the very end I'm dirty shame my last
movie about sex addicts I thought my
poor father has to watch this he's 80
years old and he's at after it was funny
but I hope I never see it again how come
you haven't done it some sense well
because that one didn't make money oh
and the books did so um basically you go
where you can tell a story where they're
gonna do it the mode do it the quickest
and give you the least resistance do you
like the edit process of books too cuz
with a film once you even if your edited
film once you shoot it it's all there
you've it's shopping a little problem is
not a repair and you have to redo
research in a book yeah that process I
mean to me getting as a writer the first
thing is to get the first draft done and
you look at it hey you just keep writing
you don't rewrite everyday and do you
just keep going and then when it's first
refuse who wrote this when you read it
and then you start to rerun and then it
becomes real but the endless process
like this book took three years which is
and I wrote a lot I do it's just the I
turn in maybe the fifth draft when it
and then you go through the copy editing
and good publishers have three different
ones where they still find a calm you
find one thing and then you have to
fact-check it and you have to go through
the whole thing with editors so it's a
long process do you let them cough sorry
do you like them copy edit you're like
only like the spelling mistakes or
semicolon here or do you let them kind
of do they want to start to dictate
content a little better
well I have a very good editor Jonathan
colossi who's very understanding I mean
I did cut two chapters out but I figured
maybe I should but you have to write it
to know so yes they give you they gave
you some thoughts and almost always I
agree with them it's a good idea but no
I don't have the words you fear or we
need to rethink this relationship was
divine your muse creatively well I
devote I wrote those movies forward to
mine the later movies I didn't write for
one specific star they were divine
vehicles especially female trouble and
pink flamingos yeah so the Bible is my
friend and real-life like every kid when
they make movies
they with her cellphone but I they make
him with her friends right cuz I always
wondered when Devine passed away did it
become difficult for you to keep writing
movies knowing that no okay I mean I
made he was supposed to be in desperate
living and he couldn't was doing a play
so I had someone else by the part and
then in Hairspray he got really great
reviews but playing the opposite of his
image yeah when he died I hired Johnny
Depp next I didn't ever work with love a
drag queen again not that I wouldn't but
I felt like I had done that and Devine
had been an early drag queen that
influenced all the new drag queens
they're all have an edge now does it
does it bug you out that you go from
making movies that are literally getting
you arrested to seeing your movie get
not only remade into a musical but
getting remade into a musical that is
now being performed at high schools high
school students are performing your work
isn't that the ultimate devious thing
I've ever done so you know I'm thrilled
by it I'm thrilled by did you use
waiting for society to realize what
you've gotten away with well it's the
Trojan horse they don't know if they're
singing a love song between two men and
encouraging their daughters to date
black guys I think it's and no one knows
that even racists like hairspray wait
they don't realize because the songs are
so nice and look at John Travolta this
is so fun they don't realize what
they're watching well but maybe they do
I don't know maybe I made him laugh so
maybe that way that a fat girl and
hairspray stood for every outsider that
possibly could be yeah and I think
that's why it worked yeah do you think
do you still advocate for a Leslie Van
Outen
I do that's serious about that I don't
talk about it much anymore because she
since I wrote the book where I advocated
her parole after being in jail from was
50 years she got three parole days the
last three and Governor Brown turned
them down and then the new governor is
deciding right now oh so she's actually
still up foot in the girl she's been
granted paroled by the prober the last
three hearings and each time only three
states California Maryland and Oklahoma
can turn down the governor has the power
to turn into but these is the parole
board he appointed and her Leslie's last
parole board they completely went
through everything that they said and
that's not true is not true she she
could let out everyone knows that she
should get out they just
don't want to be the one to do it was
she not she wasn't actually there when
it happened no it was oh she was did she
actually kill anybody
yes oh she did okay yeah who's the
driver wasn't there one of the drivers
that wasn't there that didn't commit any
murders no but we from know squeaky
Fromme but she is committed that's you
know right now it's the thing that I let
her I let them talk about it you know
they got paroled now it's it's it's been
granted it's just a legal thing that
she's her last well she got seven years
to life well she's been there 50 years
no one else in the system that gets 7 to
life would still be there and she did a
terrible thing and she is the first to
take great responsibility for that and
sarra do you still talk to Johnny Depp
yes I do
so he's dead I mean what do you guys do
I don't ask him about him married no I
just given up I know that it right now
he has a new album out with the
Hollywood vampires and he's touring with
that and somehow I'm on it because I get
all these Google Alerts of it and he
called me one day and said say something
when he was with Alice Cooper and they
were recording the album and I said some
but I don't remember what so I don't
know how I'm of I guess I'm on this new
record what do you think it is about you
the experience with you you know they
say that uh well I I haven't started any
movies myself right I don't know if you
do should yes thank you but they say
that you know on movie sets these
friendships are made these super close
friendships and then they just kind of
go away that's true you never see the
person again but for you it seems like
you do you see some I do
yeah I'm still I'm friendly with Johnny
and johnny was was very loyal to people
in Baltimore that he met then that he
has no reason to be for power or fame or
anything but he I have a friend that's a
local artist there and he had this
opening and he and Johnny were friends
we made the movie and I said to Johnny
would you send a video Johnny did a
whole video and send it into play which
made the other artists go crazy was so
amazed by so um what do you think it was
about your experience that made it so
the that broke the rule well at the time
he was almost like Justin Bieber he was
this huge teen idol for 21 Jump Street
and he hated that and I loved it and I
suppose what makes fun of that like come
with awesome
chill out he won't be and it's true when
we first that's what crybaby wasn't a
success because all that when it first
came out because all the teenage girls
went to see it and they smelled a rat
but they didn't know who and the rat was
me yeah because in a way we were making
fun of the whole image and he played the
image that he was trying to escape and
laugh about them that's always had
ballsy of Johnny Depp because you know
when you find yourself in that role to
escape it and do something like cry-baby
instead of leaning in and collecting all
the money you can possibly collect I
mean that's that's a that's a ballsy
thing to do well he did get a million
dollars for it I remember him saying to
me you got me a million is there
anything you wanted you know that you
said they did and the last one didn't
make money is there anything you really
want to do now like if they gave you
money you would do in a second well I
had two movies that I got paid to write
and haven't happen one is called
fruitcake but it's a children's
Christmas movie about a functional
family of meat thieves in Baltimore and
the other one I wrote for HBO the sequel
to hairspray and so that so who knows
they both both might happen one do they
give you a reason why they haven't done
it yet sometimes they always say oh we
like the script but we didn't know which
we were branding not or the musical I
thought Rowling you knew that before I
wrote it so it's really worse when you
meet somebody they're really big fans
they just want to meet with you and
you're like this is going [ __ ]
nowhere well it depends what they really
big fans and what are we gonna meet
about I got lots of big fans what are we
gonna talk about here are you good at
writing a script like that and then kind
of giving it a yeah I've learned to do
that that you walk away if something
doesn't happen right away in Hollywood
it usually doesn't happen so don't get
stuck right and I did once in my life
trying to make the sequel to pink
flamingos and I got stuck and I didn't
make a movie for seven years or
something or do any projects and that's
kind of why because you're obsessed with
getting that done only thing getting it
done yeah and I should have moved on
because there wasn't going to happen
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM